mes chers collègues la délégation
sénatoriale de outre-mer a engagé mardi
dernier un cycle d'audition sur les
perspectives d'évolution
institutionnelle outre-mer l'objectif
est double d'une part de faire un tour
d'horizon des souhaits d'évolution ou
pas des territoires ultramarins souhaits
qui se sont notamment exprimés au
travers de l'appel de France le 17 mai
dernier et d'autre part de mûrir la
réflexion sur une éventuelle révision
des dispositions constitutionnaires
relatives aux outre-mer à l'occasion
notamment de l'élaboration du prochain
cadre institutionnel de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour cette réflexion
nous bénéficions du rapport de mon
prédécesseur Michel Magra publié en 2020
intitulé la différenciation territoriale
d'outre-mer quel cadre pour le
sur-mesure que nous pourrons actualiser
nous avons également l'éclairage des
juristes de l'ajdom donc l'Association
des juristes d'outre-mer que nous avons
rencontré au Sénat le 29 juin dernier
pour notre troisième audition nous
accueillons cet après-midi
en présentiel et nous nous remercions
vivement car l'audition s'est monté très
vite
compte tenu de son passage sur Paris le
président de l'Assemblée territoriale de
Wallis et Futuna monsieur Mouli Yaka
le Président on considère généralement
au territoire à un statut le plus
atypique de la République je sais pas
s'il faut le dire comme ça en tout cas
on peut le considérer et nous sommes
heureux de vous donner la possibilité de
vous exprimer sur ce sujet je vais vous
céder la parole pour un propos liminaire
je vous laisse libre bien évidemment et
puis on pourra par la suite passer au
travers des questions que nous avons
adressées question qui d'ailleurs
peuvent faire l'objet de réponse écrite
par la suite et renvoyer à la délégation
donc ce qui veut dire que même si on ne
couvre pas tout dans cette audition vous
pouvez nous alimenter évidemment des
réflexions avant que nous puissions
arrêter avec Michel Jack co-rapporter le
rapport que nous présenterons d'ailleurs
au groupe décentralisation que le
président Larcher a installé cette
semaine pour intégrer des remarques au
niveau national mais juste avant je vais
laisser la parole à notre collègue de
Wallis-et-Futuna pour un propos
introductif avant de vous rendre la
parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président de la
délégation des Outre-mer au Sénat
à mon tour je souhaiterais vous
remercier tout d'abord pour
avoir bien voulu accorder un certain
temps pour recevoir accueillir les
pouvoirs échanger un peu avec sur le
président de l'Assemblée territoriale
dont
toute la délégation de l'Assemblée ici
présente
merci encore pour votre attention et
votre bienveillance et je souhaite que
cette séance sera
constructive très fructueuse en échange
et je pense que également
rien ne vaut le fait de nous retrouver
physiquement de faire un partage d'idées
tout à fait
conséquent et de vive voix merci
beaucoup monsieur le président
merci monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
Président
et donc permettez-moi avant de
entrer dans le but du sujet je
souhaiterais quand même vous adresser
dans un premier temps les salutations
les plus respectueuses
chaleureuse maintenant et merci
le président de bien vouloir nous
accueillir
dans cette salle grandiose
du Sénat
et
merci de votre accueil également
vos collaborateurs
vous adressons les salutations également
cet après-midi
donc les salutations de cet après-midi à
vous de plus respectueuse merci
salutations à vous et merci de votre
accueil
et donc par rapport à notre rencontre
d'aujourd'hui
on a eu bien sûr
cette invitation
de votre part sur le président
parce que
nous étions venus avec bien sûr des
dossiers du territoire pour les
présenter
auprès de du ministre des Outre-mer
et nous avons pu avoir l'occasion à
travers
cette invitation enfin que nous
puissions venir vous rencontrer déjà
pour une rencontre populaire dans un
premier temps mais
[Musique]
on vous écoutant avec votre introduction
bien sûr que vous rentrez déjà dans les
détails c'est à dire sur bien sûr sur
le questionnaire nous a été
proposé et
[Musique]
bien sûr
notre volonté
de vous répondre
et par rapport à toutes ces questions
mais
il nous faut du temps
bien sûr
c'est pour cela que il y avait une
demande de visioconférence
qui était prévu pour le 27
et donc par rapport à cela monsieur le
Président
on est venu
déjà pour vous rencontrer
à travers une visite autorollaire
puis
nous allons vous écouter
si
c'est l'objet de notre rencontre de cet
après-midi
pour ce questionnaire
on est à votre écoute
alors c'est vrai que vous aurez vous
aurez du temps pour répondre au
questionnaire n'a pas de difficultés
vous pourrez nous le restituer sans
aucun problème nous ce qu'on cherche à
comprendre au travers des questions
qu'on adresse aux différentes
collectivités c'est comment chacune des
collectivités vous vivez aujourd'hui
votre statut en particulier en ce qui
concerne Wallis-et-Futuna comment est-ce
que le statut actuel de cette
collectivité vous le vivez est-ce que
vous le vivez bien est-ce que il y a des
souhaits d'aller plus loin sans
forcément rentrer dans les détails parce
qu'on a bien compris qu'il y a des
collectivités qui ne voudront peut-être
pas évoluer mais nous on se pose pas
question de savoir qui doit le faire ou
pas on se pose surtout la question de
savoir si le Sénat doit accompagner ce
mouvement au niveau national à un moment
donné d'autant plus que le Président de
la République a indiqué qu'il y aurait
une évolution constitutionnelle
et que une excluait pas évidemment qu'il
y ait une évolution constitutionnelle
plus large pour d'autres territoires
ultramarins qui pourraient le souhaiter
donc il y a pas d'urgence sur le sujet
simplement on est quand même intéressé
puisque vous pratiquez le statut dans
vos fonctions de comprendre en fait
comment vous le vivez et on peut ne pas
mettre des termes juridiques dessus
parce que j'ai été élu aussi de
territoire donc je peux aussi vous
donner un ressenti de ce que je vivais
dans mon statut et c'est vraiment ça qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui s'il faut
commencer par un premier échange avec
vous c'est comment vous comment vous
vivez ça et est-ce qu'il y a des
volontés par exemple de remettre de
faire évoluer la loi qui l'a constitué
de 1961 par exemple
donc c'est une première question c'est
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous considérez ce
statut il convient parfaitement à
l'évolution de votre territoire et à la
pratique politique que vous en avez ou
est-ce que vous considérez peut-être à
un moment donné se posera la question de
faire évoluer sur des compétences
différentes
voire même de restituer des compétences
enfin voilà où la relation avec l'État
qui nous intéresse également de la
comprendre puisque on a bien compris que
c'est quand je dis atypique c'est que
c'est une relation qui n'existe pas
ailleurs en outre-mer donc c'est
intéressant aussi de comprendre comment
comment elle est vécue et si c'est une
évolution qui peut être souhaitée ou pas
donc voilà les choses sont je peux pas
l'exprimer de manière plus simple je
pense c'est vraiment un ressenti de ce
que vous vivez aujourd'hui au travers de
votre de votre statut
merci monsieur le Président et par
rapport à votre
première question
et pour
[Musique]
l'idée d'une révolution statutaire
je pense que
nous sommes partants bien sûr pour une
évolution statutaire sauf que pour pour
l'instant
nous ne sommes pas en mesure déjà de
nous prononcer
par rapport à
un éventuel évolution
il faut que vous compreniez monsieur le
président
il y a une situation que tu mets
qui nous préoccupe actuellement au
niveau de Wallis
mais également il faut une conception
de la de toute la population
mais aussi savoir que
notre statut 61
il y a quand même une part de
responsabilité de nos de nos coutumier
c'est pour cela que pour l'instant
nous ne sommes pas encore en mesure de
vous
[Musique]
de vous dire
que il faut il faut passer à l'étape
c'est à dire sur
une évolution de notre statut
j'ai le formuler autrement est-ce que
vous êtes satisfait des relations par
exemple que vous avez avec l'État est-ce
que pour vous vous êtes satisfait de la
situation actuelle ou est-ce que et ce
que je vous dis là Président c'est pas
un piège pour vous prononcer sur une
évolution statutaire qu'on pourrait vous
reprocher sur le territoire c'est
simplement des discussions qu'on peut
avoir entre le Sénat qui s'intéresse et
veut évidemment collectivités parce que
nous sommes quand même votre vos
représentants au niveau national donc le
Sénat et la Chambre des représentants
des collectivités c'est c'est vraiment
de comprendre si au-delà des
consultations vous avez raison de le
rappeler nécessaire pour une évolution
statutaire et ça effectivement on a tous
intégré on est même pas là vous voyez on
est vraiment à se dire est-ce que il
faut ou pas se poser la question tout
simplement il y a les territoires je
suis persuadés qui vont vous dire nous
on se pose même pas la question de
changer ça nous voit très bien très bien
s'il y a pas besoin de changer il y a
pas besoin de changer est-ce qu'on veut
surtout pas manquer c'est l'opportunité
qui va être donnée de se donner
l'occasion de pouvoir évoluer le cas
échéant après chaque territoire aura le
temps nécessaire et son temps
personne ne l'imposera aucun territoire
de toute façon donc chaque territoire
aura 100 ans de réflexion nécessaire
mais c'est vrai que le rapport à la
coutume est intéressant parce que c'est
la coutume occupe une place bien
particulière dans l'organisation
actuelle
et ça faisait partie d'ailleurs des
questions qu'on se posait de savoir si
s'il fallait faire évoluer cette place
ou si c'est une place qui convient à
tous les acteurs au regard de la manière
dont les choses se passent voilà donc ce
sont des ce sont vraiment des questions
qui pour nous sont intéressantes à nous
poser au regard de ce qu'on connaît
d'autres statuts parce que c'est quand
même assez inédit et c'est vrai que loin
de nous de toute façon on sait là la
volonté de toucher un territoire plus
qu'un autre c'est pas c'est pas le sujet
on est là pour recenser et comprendre
voilà si vous nous dites effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes pas en mesure de vous
positionner c'est même pas pour nous
c'est pas le sujet on n'est pas on n'est
pas on est vraiment en se disant est-ce
que un moment donné cette question peut
ou pas se poser si elle se pose pas il
se pose pas c'est pas voilà j'espère
avoir pu clarifier un petit peu mais tu
pourras compléter si tu veux Michel
quand c'est la crise de Saint-Barthélémy
qui est mon corps rapporteur sur ce
rapport que nous présenterons par la
suite au président Larcher qui est très
très attentif également
à ce qu'on pourra à faire en sorte
premièrement qu'on continue à défendre
notre mère c'est quand même le troll et
puis que lui également puisse porter au
niveau national des souhaits des
souhaits le moment où merci président
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
messieurs le ministre
mes chers collègues c'est comme le
disait Stéphane Artano parfois nous
sommes tous des territoires ultramarins
nous nous sommes à des milliers de
kilomètres les uns les autres et nous
avons chacun notre mode et notre
attachement à la coutume
la terre et même si j'ai lu un peu
l'organisation de votre territoire mais
est-ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
enfin m'expliquer à moi particulièrement
comment est organisé entre la coutume
entre
l'action de l'État entre le Conseil
comment les choses s'articulent et quels
sont les liens et qui qui est
responsable de quoi parce que je vous
avoue que sur une petite île de 21 km²
j'ai dû je n'arrive enfin j'ai du mal à
percevoir un petit peu cette
organisation je suis très respectueuse
justement des territoires et des
habitants et de leur de leur coutume
merci madame la sénatrice merci bien de
votre pour répondre à votre question et
nous avons quatre forces
institutions qui composent justement
l'organisation de notre territoire
le
nous avons l'état
nous avons
nos coutumier nous avons également notre
religion
et nous avons
nos politiques
ça représente quand même les quatre
forces vives de notre territoire
[Musique]
et
notre relation avec l'État
moi je dirais que nous avons de très
bonnes relations avec l'État sauf que
avec
les deux casquettes
dans le sur le préfet
occupe
sur le territoire c'est à dire qu'il est
que représente l'exécutif et aussi il
est aussi administrateur supérieur là il
représente l'État
tout ça nous aimerions que
quand même que la partie territoriale
nous revienne ça c'est
c'est notre
c'est notre vision
mais comme je vous ai
évoqué tout à l'heure
pour l'instant
il faut quand même qu'on
commence à travailler avec toutes ces
forces vives j'ai seulement pour pouvoir
nous prononcer par rapport à notre à une
position commune et
[Musique]
par rapport à notre décision souvent
justement si on souhaite
on est bien partant pour
une évolution mais
quelle évolution voilà il faut qu'on
définisse bien les
orientales l'orientation que nous
devions bien sûr
pour que qu'on sache
quelle évolution statutaire nous allons
devoir appliquer
sur le président
d'information
et un aperçu également de notre ressenti
local où les estomacs je peux vous dire
que
je l'ai évoqué déjà
la semaine dernière lors de notre
réunion
l'audition du ministre des Outre-mer
Jean-François Carenco
en tout cas moi personnellement j'ai un
ressenti négatif et très frustré du fait
que
on est la seule collectivité actuelle
française ou d'outre-mer
à avoir l'exécutif entre les mains du
représentant de l'État alors que depuis
2003 nous avons quand même la
décentralisation avec les modifications
qui ont été apportées
à la Constitution de 1958 et aujourd'hui
on doit décider de notre avenir
institutionnel
par contre
ce que le président a évoqué tout à
l'heure le fait que
l'exemple est là il y a rien de il y a
rien à inventé le préfet à tous les
pouvoirs
maintenant il y a une conjugaison bien
sûr avec les chiffres du maire parce que
c'est ce que
stipule en tant que spécificité notre
statut de 61 mais aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression
qu'on fait de sur place un peu dans on
stats un peu si on veut avancer si on
veut faire évoluer ce statut ou pas
alors que on se plaint tout le temps du
fait que tous les pouvoirs sont entre
les mains du préfet qui est représentant
de l'État et chef du territoire en même
temps comme c'est indiqué dans le statut
de 61
il y a bien sûr un consensus a trouvé au
niveau de l'Assemblée territoriale pour
faire évoluer les choses mais en tout
cas si je peux me permettre de donner un
avis tout à fait personnel je suggère en
tout cas vis-à-vis de notre collectivité
de
qu'on fasse évoluer les choses de
manière positive pour les windiens il
faut tenir parce que si on se plaint
tout le temps de cette situation
complexe
mais qu'on admet et qu'on
accepte quand même de
laisser les choses telles qu'elles je ne
comprends plus rien j'ai l'impression
qu'on fait de sur place et qu'on demande
à faire évoluer mais qu'on accepte quand
même à laisser les choses telles
qu'elles choses qui qui sont
complètement contradictoires voilà un
peu monsieur le Président ainsi que mes
chers collègues sénateurs sénatrice mon
ressenti personnel que j'ai envie de
partager ici parce que c'est l'occasion
pour nous de d'échanger de manière
directe et de vive voix et je crois que
pour la délégation de volts qui est
présente devant nous c'est vraiment
l'occasion de dire ce que l'on pense et
de commencer à
élaguer un peu avant de prendre une
décision finale parce que je comprends
la difficulté je comprends que toutes
les toutes les instances qui doivent
intervenir
pour arriver à une décision finale
ça me semble difficile à aborder mais je
pense que quand on parle de référendum
c'est un fait c'est la loi c'est la
démocratie mais
vous comprenez très bien je viens que
moi que si on demande à quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais été à l'école c'est péjoratif
quand je parle comme ça qui n'a jamais
été à l'école et qui ne comprend pas qui
ne sait pas lire de donner son avis sur
l'évolution statutaire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'est-ce que
vous voulez attendre qu'on me Raiponce
de ce genre de catégorie de personnes
encore une fois je
ne veux pas être
péjoratif dans mes propos mais je veux
dire que
il faut à un moment donné il faut qu'on
prenne les choses en main et qu'on
avance on avance les instances de
direction et je dirais de gestion du
territoire doivent
prendre l'initiative de faire avancer
les choses de manière à ce qu'on arrive
à un résultat résultat positif et qui
conviennent aux bolivien d'abord et au
futur
après les discussions et les
négociations avec l'État français sont à
venir et sont à détailler ensuite avec
des accords pour rédiger on va dire un
statut final on modifié mais j'estime
que à l'heure actuelle déjà rien qu'avec
le fait que on est la seule collectivité
qui qui a encore l'exécutif entre les
mains du représentant de l'État c'est
pas normal on constate bien qu'il y a
une anomalie qu'on n'arrive pas à
dépasser on n'arrive pas à assumer et
moi je pense que à l'heure actuelle il
faut il faut on avance il faut qu'on
fasse évoluer les choses il faut qu'on
prenne des initiatives positives pour la
communauté Colisée
excusez-moi si j'ai été un peu long mais
je suis un peu
je voudrais dire que je profite vraiment
de l'occasion parce qu'on n'a jamais
l'occasion de discuter de Walt Disney et
de son statut spécifique vraiment
spécifique parce que je pense que c'est
la seule
collectivité où on a encore
des chiffres coutumières actives et
existantes et mentionné dans les statuts
de l'État merci monsieur le Président ce
qui ce qui chers collègues effectivement
nécessite de trouver un équilibre sur le
territoire un équilibre qu'on comprend
tous donc il y a aucune vraiment aucune
difficulté là-dessus d'ailleurs mais
c'est vrai que sur sur la manière
d'engager la réflexion alors nous on
mène le travail que le Sénat a déjà venu
en 2020 on interrogeant les différents
outre-mer et puis je pense que vous avez
des destinataires monsieur le Président
ces jours-ci d'un courrier
signé des deux ministres ministres de
l'outre-mer et du ministre délégué sur
la méthode que va utiliser le
gouvernement pour organiser des
consultations
avec un comité de suivi enfin je sais
plus comment ils l'ont appelé d'ailleurs
avec chaque exécutif
ultramarin on partant en faisant la
démarche inverse c'est-à-dire en
reprenant l'ensemble des thématiques
environnementales et autres de chacun
des territoires en voyant ce qu'ils font
et ce qui ne fonctionne pas et en
arrivant et c'est la vision de l'État on
arrive en terme à dire puisque ça ça ne
fonctionne pas effectivement peut-être
qu'une évolution du statut pourrait être
nécessaire pour ce territoire en
particulier voilà c'est la méthode
gouvernementale qui va être appliquée
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même un
mouvement aujourd'hui qu'ils engage au
niveau y compris parisien de dire on va
regarder sur les territoires si il y a
un champ de compétences par exemple sur
lequel il y a des difficultés est-ce que
ça nécessite simplement de modifier une
loi qui existe déjà par exemple et
parfois du statut ça peut être une loi
sur une thématique de l'énergie par
exemple ou de l'environnement où est-ce
que justement ça va plus loin que que
simplement cette loi là et est-ce que
par exemple ça touche
la manière dont la compétence peut
exercer sur le territoire c'est un peu
la manière dont les choses visiblement
vont être vont être abordés c'est pas
tout à fait nous ce qu'on évoque avec
nos collègues on est vraiment sur un
étage constitutionnel c'est de dire
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les deux articles
qui concernent l'outre-mer pour
simplifier le 73 et 74 est-ce qu'on a
besoin de de les ouvrir encore un peu
plus pour donner encore plus de
disponibles de marge de manœuvre au
territoire ultramarin pour ceux qui en
auraient envie et puis ceux qu'on a
envie derrière il va falloir qu'il
réfléchissent à la manière dont ils
pourront le mettre en oeuvre donc vous
voyez c'est vraiment à deux étages et
tout ça c'est sur un ton qui est long
mais les réformes constitutionnelles en
France elles seront quasiment tous les
15 ans donc c'est simplement de se dire
est-ce que est-ce qu'on bouge ou pas
maintenant on élargissant le champ des
possibilités et à chaque territoire à ce
enfin nous on a une vision là-dessus qui
qui est assez ouvrière sont des
possibles et chaque territoire fera son
choix en responsabilité de dire nous on
veut bouger là-dessus ou pas on
faire évoluer on veut récupérer
l'exécutif ou pas parce que il peut y
avoir aussi une décision de votre
territoire de conserver le statu quo ce
qui est tout à fait compréhensible ou au
contraire de le faire évoluer et c'est
tout aussi légitime donc c'est vraiment
on est vraiment sur sur cette dimension
là d'essayer de comprendre en fait si
déjà donc votre vécu mais vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président il
y a quand même des choses puisque vous
avez avancé sur le fait que déjà sur le
principe de réfléchir je pense que vous
êtes déjà dans ces dynamique le fait
d'avoir rencontré le ministre de carinco
ici je pense que ça ça contribue et je
pense que collègues étaient également
présent à l'Elysée le 7 le 7 septembre
dernier autour du président de la
République et la première ministre pour
pour commencer à évoquer un peu cette
réflexion également donc voilà on est
vraiment sur sur ça et sans forcément
rentrer dans le détail aujourd'hui parce
que c'est pas forcément le sujet non
plus encore une fois on a du temps nous
rapporte on devrait le restituer je
pense Novembre Décembre maintenant parce
que on va rapporter au groupe de travail
du quai présidé par le président Larcher
donc ça ça va arriver au mois de mars a
priori donc on a encore un peu de temps
pour pour collecter un peu les
informations et puis le gouvernement de
toute façon lui va lancer au travers du
préfet du territoire les concertations
avec votre collectivité
tel que je l'ai vu sur la feuille de
route pour mon territoire donc je vous
en parle puisque j'ai vu courrier donc
c'est quand même intéressant de voir un
peu comment ça va être comment ça va
être abordé quoi
je parle un peu trop mais je crois que
c'est le bon moment pour pouvoir
échanger
je crois que
ce président de l'Assemblée territoriale
ainsi que mes chers collègues élus
je crois qu'il y a pas meilleur moment
pour profiter de l'élan
gouvernemental pour
activer et accélérer la réflexion
là-dessus parce que
comme disait le Président si on attend
tous les 15 ans
jamais avec notre mort nature ou la
prochaine mandature on pourra arriver à
quoi que ce soit donc il est opportun de
profiter de l'élan national à faire
fusionner parce que il s'agit de savoir
si on veut à la demande de toutes les
collectivités d'outre-mer si on veut
fusionner faire fusionner
les articles 113 74 de la Constitution
pour nous laisser des ouvertures ceux
qui nous permettra de réfléchir
positivement pour tout ce qui nous
reviendrait comme acquis ou comme
prérogative à apprendre à l'avenir qui
qui nous rapporterait un peu plus
d'ouverture dans la gestion de notre
territoire et je pense que c'est quelque
chose de très positif pour nous et il
est temps qu'on y réfléchisse rapidement
tant que l'élan national et là pour nous
aider et pour nous accompagner merci
monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président et je
remercie également le propos de Monsieur
je comprends parfaitement
les propos venaient de nous évoquer sur
le sénateur
comme je vous ai évoqué tout à l'heure
pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas encore
ambitieux de vous de nous positionner et
de nous prononcer pour
une telle évolution de statuteurs de
notre territoire
la fusion
des articles 73 74 dans
Monsieur le Sénateur nous nous parle
il est vrai que
pour
les dômes et comme
à travers
cette fusion là
on voit peut-être y arriver mais
laissez-nous le temps et de
porter et de traiter
ce dossier pour une
pour une projection sur une évolution
statutaire et pour l'instant comme je
vous ai évoqué
on souhaite tout d'abord que les quatre
forces vives de notre territoire puis-je
bien sûr ce concerter et travailler en
amont justement pour
bien sûr décider quel sera le la
décision que nous allons prendre
ensemble pour l'avenir de notre
territoire
et je vais je vais revenir juste à
l'étage le plus supérieur possible pour
vous donner un exemple de ce que je
pense
si vous me posez la question en tant
qu’on sien président de la collectivité
de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon que j'ai été
pendant
si aujourd'hui la fusion de l'article 73
74 me pose une difficulté
je vous répondrai que ça ne pose aucune
difficulté si on ne m'enlève rien et si
on me laisse tout le possible voilà
c'est à dire qu'en réalité
nous nous avons quand même des latitudes
qui sont assez importantes et à partir
du moment où cette rédaction
constitutionnelle touchera en rien le
statut de mon territoire me permettrait
de pouvoir évoluer si un jour j'en ai
envie
je pense que ça me pose pas de
difficultés c'est pas c'est pas chez
nous forcément que le débat va être le
plus vif me semble-t-il puisque le
statut des collectivités est quand même
un statut qui donne une entre guillemets
une certaine autonomie administrative
sur un certain nombre de champs de
compétences donc c'est vrai que moi je
fixe vraiment le débat à ce niveau là
aussi c'est ce qu'au niveau
constitutionnel ça pose déjà une
difficulté si jamais le gouvernement par
exemple voulait à terme proposer une
modification et le ministre qui a un
coin était très prudent en disant qu'on
ne le fera que si c'est nécessaire et on
le fera que si ça apporte au territoire
concerné de la valeur ajoutée en termes
de développement économique et de
cohésion sociale
le gouvernement a mis quand même des
garde-fous sur cette évolution et c'est
bien dans ce sens là et on ne demandera
pas dans nos auditions
aux collectivités de nous donner la
feuille de route de leur évolution
statutaire on pose des questions sur un
ressenti le projet c'est pas nous quand
on l'écrire parce que chaque territoire
de toute façon sera à terme consulté
s'il le souhaite c'est chaque territoire
qui décidera non pas mettre dans l'autre
rapport les articles tels qui devraient
être rédiger c'est pas du tout l'objet
de du sel on est bien d'accord on est
vraiment sur est-ce que cette fusion 73
elle ouvre au contraire des possibles
plus qu'elle ne ferme pas c'est bien ça
le sujet ce qu'on veut surtout c'est
permettre à tous les territoires qui le
voudront le jeu moment venu de pouvoir
choisir une voie qu'ils n'ont peut-être
pas la possibilité de choisir
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment cette
approche là qu'on essaye qui nous guide
en tout cas enfin merci de merci de la
franchise de vos propos au moins c'est
clair il vous faut du temps mais vous
n'êtes pas les seuls je vous rassure je
pense que tous les territoires ont
besoin de temps ce qu'on sait c'est que
il y aura et vous l'avez dit nécessité
de consulter localement
surtout les territoires on a tous la
même sujet c'est que tous ces sujets
nécessitent de trouver un équilibre je
pense que vous l'avez également
également rappelé donc c'est un sujet
qui s'inscrit dans un temps long mais un
temps constitutionnel qui devrait je
pense amener le gouvernement à prendre
peut-être une position je regarde plus
administrateurs mais sans doute vers fin
2023 me semble-t-il puisque il y a une
contrainte évidemment de légiférer sur
la Nouvelle-Calédonie et que c'est sans
doute à cette occasion que sur le volet
constitutionnel j'entends donc le niveau
le plus élevé il y a une question qui va
se poser le niveau après des territoires
lui c'est un deuxième niveau il peut
être décalé dans le temps en fonction du
choix des différents territoires donc on
n'est pas du tout sur les mêmes
calendriers mais c'est intéressant de
poser déjà des questions au territoire
parce qu'on fait ce qu'on s'est rendu
compte c'est que entre 2020 et 2022 il y
a différents territoires qui ont évolué
dans leur position par rapport à ce qui
nous avait dit déjà en 2020 donc c'est
intéressant de comprendre aussi pourquoi
en deux ans les choses ont évolué et
donc
un processus d'accompagnement de ces
évolutions notre rôle c'est d'être à vos
côtés à leurs côtés pour l'accompagner
dans la mesure où on légifère évidemment
ici en tout cas merci beaucoup de
vous être rendu disponible au pied
élevés parce que on a organisé ça assez
rapidement dans la mesure où on
préférait vous avoir en visuel président
et Mesdames Messieurs qu'on
visioconférence avec le décalage qu'on
connaît et qu'on connaît tous et qu'on
le pratique dans tout nos territoires et
donc c'était bien de pouvoir avoir ce
premier contact et puis bien évidemment
on est preneur par la suite
des éléments que vous avez bien nous
faire remonter sur la trame de questions
qu'on vous adressez qui pour nous une un
guide de réflexion plus qu'autre chose
c'est voilà c'est ce qu'on va intégrer
dans le rapport final en tout cas merci
beaucoup et je vous souhaite un bon
séjour à Paris merci
est-ce qu'on va se faire une photo de
groupe